are you still buddies with jim jimmy
kimmel have you kept in touch
lately because i moved back to new york
for a couple years ago i haven't really
talked to him in a while and also like
there's so many people that come in and
out of his life that do entertainment
and you know i had a kind of
i was not just a one-off you know he
[ __ ] produced my whole show and i was
like with the word mtv show yeah he's
the one who got me my mtv show oh
wow i didn't know that he did that
that's sick yeah
so
tony de santo was an mtv exec and was
always going to jimmy saying let's do a
show let's do a shoulder show jimmy was
like really really busy
and then like a year so after he found
me he kept telling me he's like all the
bits on my show are good but i think
your original comedy that i found you
from those weird little videos you did
on the internet i think that could be
something so
he finally like found the time he
brought me in and he pitched me to them
he's like finally i got a show for you
we did a pilot
[ __ ] was jimmy kimmel ever on the
show he was yeah he was one of the
guests
um and he's very [ __ ] loyal man he's
like super like even
in the last like
not in the last few years but like maybe
five six years ago i had some other
ideas he like helped me pitch
he's like
took time out of his day to like be in a
video pitch to help me pitch other [ __ ]
like he's a very loyal [ __ ] cool dude
like i know him a lot yeah very gentle
yeah i like him a lot too man i i really
do you ever go to one of his crazy
parties that you hear about yeah the
best one for a fat [ __ ] like me is like
um there's an italian
thing i think it's on new year's or
around new year's
where they don't eat meat they only eat
seafood and they make like seven or
eleven different i think it's a
seven fish seven fishes yeah
so just like i'm a big seafood fan and
he just had like seven different kinds
of like seafood at this big ass [ __ ]
party
that [ __ ] was fire what kind of parties
did you throw dude like you heard about
it on like howard stern and [ __ ] it's
just like
straight nothing but [ __ ]
like a-list
you know george clooney's [ __ ] at the
party and like just like i don't think
i've been to that because that's
probably
like
i was on a show and my show came out and
the
kind of the earlier years of his show
so like i did more kind of like intimate
things where it was just like six people
going to watch football
and he's such a workaholic he would be
in his room for half the time like
writing and [ __ ] right um and like yeah
like the
new year's party type [ __ ] but not like
the whole actor [ __ ] you know what i
mean yeah like knoxville would be at
those parties and stuff and like
it's just crazy man like it's the stuff
of legend
wow yeah
it's epic
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
foreign